Le philosophe, le sage, qui conseille le
prince — c’est un schéma récurrent.
Voltaire a tenu ce rôle auprès de Frédéric
II de Prusse, qui l’a invité à Berlin.
Et voici ce que ce roi a déclaré
à propos du philosophe :
« Voltaire est le plus méchant fou que j'aie
connu de ma vie ; il n'est bon qu'à lire. Vous
ne sauriez imaginer toutes les duplicités,
les fourberies et les infamies qu'il a faites
ici ; je suis indigné que tant d'esprit et
tant de connaissances ne rendent pas les
hommes meilleurs... »
Wow vraiment ?
La vie de Voltaire, le plus grand philosophe
français des Lumières, est exceptionnelle.
La biographie de Max Gallo
se lit comme un roman.
Je l’ai d’autant plus appréciée qu’elle met bien
en évidence une dimension essentielle — et à mes
yeux la plus intéressante — du destin de
Voltaire : son pouvoir d’influence.
Armé de sa plume et de ses idées, Voltaire est
craint par des rois qui ont des armées.
Une autre dimension fascinante
de la vie de Voltaire,
c’est qu’il n’est pas du tout lisse.
Il passe aujourd’hui pour le défenseur de la
liberté et de la tolérance, mais vous allez
voir, comme le suggère la citation du début
de la vidéo, que Voltaire n’est pas du tout
un homme exemplaire sur le plan moral.
Il y a tant de choses fascinantes et
révélatrices dans sa vie que j’ai eu
du mal à me limiter à 10 anecdotes. J’ai
donc gardé les tout meilleures.
Mais vous allez voir que les dernières
sont… un peu choquantes.
« Les chiens ne font pas des
chats », dit l’adage.
Mais si Voltaire est si original et si épris
de liberté, ce n’est pas dû à ses parents.
Son père, François Arouet, était certes un
lettré — mais c’était surtout un notaire,
un bourgeois concentré sur ses affaires, qui
faisait des leçons de morale à son fils, dont il
s’attendait à ce qu’il reprenne son flambeau.
Voltaire méprise son père comme un homme ennuyeux.
Donc il prétend être un enfant illégitime.
Son véritable géniteur serait un certain
« Roquebrune ». Voltaire se félicite que sa
mère ait préféré cet homme, un officier qui
était un intellectuel et un auteur.
En fait, l’homme qui a fait Voltaire,
c’est son parrain.
François de Castagnère, l’abbé de
Châteauneuf, est un ami proche, et peut-être
même l’amant de la mère de Voltaire.
D’où l’intérêt qu’il porte à l’enfant : il
veille à sa santé et à son éducation.
Or, cet homme qui se fait le protecteur
de Voltaire est… un curé libertin ! C’est
un homme très original, épris de liberté
dans ses pensées comme dans ses actes.
À l’évidence, l’esprit de Voltaire
est le fruit de son influence.
L’abbé de Châteauneuf lui transmet
d’abord son amour des lettres.
Constatant la précocité du jeune Voltaire,
il lui apprend à rimer ; il lui fait lire
et réciter les fables de La Fontaine.
Ensuite, il lui transmet son scepticisme.
Il lui fait notamment lire des textes (censurés)
qui dénoncent les mensonges de la religion.
Enfin, il l’initie aux plaisirs. Lorsque Voltaire
est adolescent, son parrain l’introduit dans des
cercles libertins où on joue des sommes folles
et où on multiplie les aventures sexuelles.
Vous connaissez le préjugé selon lequel les
intellectuels sont des « fragiles » — c’est-à-dire
qu’ils sont faibles physiquement. On imagine que
le développement de l’esprit se fait forcément au
détriment de celui du corps, et réciproquement.
Ou bien on constate que la faiblesse du corps
favorise l’activité de l’esprit.
Ce préjugé n’est pas toujours vérifié,
mais il l’est avec Voltaire.
Il sera faible, et souvent malade,
tout au long de sa longue vie.
À sa naissance, déjà, il est si frêle que sa
nourrice prédit chaque jour qu’il va mourir.
Il est un grand homme maigre, avec un teint
maladif. Seuls ses yeux laissent deviner
le désir et l’énergie qui l’habitent.
Il est souvent malade au point de ne pouvoir
travailler ni même se déplacer. À trente ans,
il est contaminé par l’épidémie de petite vérole
qui sévit à Paris, et il croit bien y passer.
Il verra encore la mort s’approcher à diverses
reprises — mais il vivra jusqu’à 83 ans !
Rendu impuissant vers la fin de la quarantaine
par son éternelle faiblesse, il se justifie à une
maîtresse en lui disant : « Je suis né tué ».
Et plus il vieillit, plus il paraît malade. À
partir de la soixantaine, il n’est plus
qu’un squelette. On murmure autour de
lui que ses jours sont comptés.
Comme sa nourrice 60 ans plus tôt !
On connaît Voltaire comme un philosophe, donc on
se dit qu’il écrit en prose, c’est-à-dire pas sous
forme de vers. Les écrivains des Lumières
préfèrent la prose et abandonnent les vers,
parce qu’ils considèrent que la prose est le
moyen approprié pour faire parler la raison.
Antoine de Rivarol écrit ainsi dans le
discours qu’il a écrit pour entrer à
l'Académie de Berlin en 1784, De l’universalité
de la langue française : « C’est la prose qui
donne l’empire à une langue, parce
qu’elle est tout usuelle ; la poésie
n’est qu’un objet de luxe ».
Montesquieu, un autre des plus grands
philosophes des Lumières, était allé plus loin
en écrivant dans les Lettres persanes que « les
poètes sont des auteurs dont le métier est de
mettre des entraves au bon sens et d'accabler
la raison sous les agréments ».
Mais Voltaire fait exception.
Il est le seul qui ne renonce pas aux vers. Il
continue de penser, comme les auteurs classiques,
que la prose est un registre inférieur.
Son goût et son talent pour les vers se
manifestent dès l’adolescence. À 15 ans, il est
déjà connu à Louis-Le-Grand comme un virtuose.
Il veut se faire remarquer : on dit de lui qu’«
il est dévoré de la soif de la célébrité ».
Convaincu de son destin littéraire, il néglige
les études de droit auxquelles le contraint son
père. Il passe son temps à écrire des vers et
à les réciter dans des salons libertins.
Il commencera d’ailleurs sa carrière
d’écrivain avec des tragédies en vers.
Sa grande aisance à jongler avec les mots
font déjà de lui, au début de la vingtaine,
un de homme de lettres mondain, qui gravite
dans les cercles du pouvoir à Paris. Ses mots
d’esprit régalent dans les dîners… mais sa
liberté ne plaira pas à tout le monde.
On dit toujours « Voltaire »,
sans préciser son prénom.
C’est vrai qu’on dit aussi généralement
« Rousseau », sans préciser le prénom,
quand on parle de l’autre génie des Lumières
françaises — mais on dit bien de temps en
temps « JEAN-JACQUES Rousseau ». D’ailleurs,
certaines couvertures de ses livres précisent
le prénom « Jean-Jacques ».
Alors pourquoi ne donne-ton
jamais le prénom de Voltaire ?
Eh bien parce que « Voltaire » est
un nom de plume.
C’est le nom de plume
de « François Marie Arouet ».
Mais pourquoi avoir pris un nom de plume ?
Il y a déjà le fait que Voltaire méprise
son père, cet homme sans génie.
Et puis le nom « Arouet » sonne bourgeois ; et
il peut être compris comme « à rouer ». Bref,
c’est un nom fade, sans énergie.
D’où vient le nom « Voltaire » ?
D’une pièce de théâtre (aujourd’hui inconnue) dont
le héros est un fils incestueux qui maudissait
les Dieux. Et ce héros s’appelle « Voltare ».
Alors qu’il n’a pas encore réussi à faire jouer sa
première tragédie, François Marie Arouet joue avec
le nom « Voltare » : c’est proche du latin volare,
qui signifie « vouloir » ; c’est également proche
de « volontaire ». Il ajoute un i après le a,
ce qui donne « Voltaire ».
Voltaire est l’auteur
emblématique des Lumières françaises.
Il est si célèbre qu’on dit parfois du français
qu’il est « la langue de Voltaire » (même si on
dit plus souvent « la langue de Molière »).
Du coup, beaucoup de gens s’imaginent —
et c’est peut-être aussi votre cas — que
Voltaire a fait rayonner la langue et l’esprit
français depuis leur épicentre, Paris.
Eh bien non !
Voltaire aurait bien voulu passer ses jours
parmi les élites parisiennes, mais sa vie n’a été
qu’un long exil à l’écart de la capitale.
Cela a commencé pendant ses études de droit.
Son père, au fait de l’assiduité de son fils
aux salons libertins, l’envoie à Caen pour
le calmer. Puis lorsqu’il apprend que l’exilé
n’est pas moins libertin en province, il le
menace de l’envoyer moisir en Amérique.
Ensuite, c’est le pouvoir qui exile Voltaire.
Une partie des puissants ne goûtent pas
son éloquence et sa liberté de ton.
L’épisode le plus célèbre l’oppose au chevalier
de Rohan-Chabot. Au début de la trentaine, il
se prend le bec avec ce descendant de l'une des
lignées les plus aristocratiques du royaume. Il
l’humilie en lui disant qu’il n’est pas digne du
prestige de son nom : « Je commence mon nom, et
vous, vous finissez le vôtre ». Quelques jours
plus tard, le chevalier se venge en envoyant ses
laquais frapper Voltaire à coups de gourdin.
Voltaire veut se venger à son tour, mais voilà…
Son adversaire est protégé par le pouvoir, alors
qu’il n’est, lui, qu’un poète talentueux.
Donc pour ne pas passer sa vie en prison à cause
de ce conflit, il part s’installer en Angleterre
3 mois plus tard. C’est le début d’un long
exil. Souvent, il voudra se réinstaller
à Paris, mais ses ennemis — politiques ou
religieux — l’en empêcheront.
Il vivra notamment en province,
en Angleterre, en Allemagne, et en Suisse.
Il retournera à Paris la dernière année de sa vie,
et il y connaîtra un triomphe qui
le fera mourir d’épuisement.
Aujourd’hui, Voltaire est probablement un des
auteurs les plus classiques de la littérature
et de la philosophie françaises. Ses livres
sont dans tous les programmes scolaires et
dans toutes les librairies. Il est cité par
les hommes politiques de tous les bords.
Il est une référence incontournable du
patrimoine culturel français — et plus
précisémént, du SYSTÈME POLITIQUE français.
Eh bien, à son époque, c’était L’INVERSE.
Voltaire a été une victime quasi permanente
de la censure. Pour se protéger, il écrit
sous pseudonyme ; puis il recourt à des
imprimeurs clandestins qui travaillent
rapidement (avant que les autorités n’aient le
temps d’intervenir) ; ou bien il fait imprimer
ses textes à l’étranger.
S’il est censuré, c’est d’abord
parce qu’il s’attaque aux puissants.
Par exemple, sa toute première tragédie,
Œdipe, bénéficie du bouche à oreille avant même
d’être jouée parce qu’elle contiendrait une
allusion à la rumeur selon laquelle Philippe
d’Orléans (le régent qui dirige la France
en attendant que Louis XV grandisse) aurait
une relation incestueuse avec sa fille.
La censure s’explique aussi par le fait que
Voltaire se met à dos les religieux.
Il écrit par exemple dans la
même pièce, sa toute première,
Œdipe : « Nos prêtres ne sont point ce
qu'un vain peuple pense / Notre crédulité
fait toute leur science ».
APRÈS, le rapport de Voltaire
au pouvoir est ambigü.
Il tient certes des propos
controversés qui lui valent la prison, l’exil,
et même jusqu’à des menaces physiques.
Mais de l’autre côté, une partie des élites
françaises le soutient. Et Voltaire sait arrondir
les angles quand c’est dans son intérêt.
Tout au long de sa vie, il essaie de séduire
la royauté pour obtenir des avantages
et la reconnaissance. Il a par exemple
été titulaire pendant quelques années d'une
charge officielle d'historiographe de Louis
XV (c’est-à-dire qu’il est chargé d’écrire
l’histoire du règne), et il a fait campagne
pour être élu à l’Académie française.
Il a également essayé, à certains moments,
de séduire les autorités ecclésiastiques
lorsqu’il en allait de son intérêt.
Certains reprochent à Bernard-Henri
Lévy (ou « BHL ») d’être riche.
Ils l’appellent le « philosophe milliardaire
» pour sous-entendre que sa fortune, et donc
son rapport à l’argent, corrompt son rapport au
savoir. Bref, il est si riche qu’il ne pourrait
pas être un véritable philosophe !
Eh bien Voltaire était un peu dans la
même situation !
En termes relatif,
il était aussi, sinon plus riche que BHL.
Et puis il s’est enrichi par lui-même,
tandis que BHL est un héritier.
Mais la réputation de Voltaire était
certainement pire !
En effet, l’argent
n’avait pas d’odeur pour lui.
À la trentaine, il réalise que son talent
et ses relations ne le protègent pas du pouvoir.
Il veut donc gagner l’argent de sa liberté — et
aucune limite morale ne peut l’en empêcher.
« J'ai vu, dit-il, tant de gens de lettres pauvres
et méprisés que j'ai conclu dès longtemps que
je ne devais pas en augmenter le nombre. »
Il multipliera donc les opérations douteuses,
les investissements interdits, et les délits
d’initié. Il s’associera avec des affairistes
qui, grâce à leurs connexions politiques,
font de très gros profits sur le dos de
l’État (c’est la bonne vieille recette
de la privatisation de l’argent public). Il
estime que fournir les armées est le moyen le
meilleur moyen de s’enrichir. Il profite donc
des guerres pour faire grossir sa fortune.
Il frôle à plusieurs reprises le scandale
public, mais il met toute son énergie et
sa mauvaise foi à étouffer les affaires.
Les revenus de ses investissements lui assurent
un train de vie de prince sans jamais entamer
son capital. Il deviendra si riche qu’il se
permettra d’être le créancier de
quelques princes européens.
Avec une telle fortune, on peut se
reposer et profiter de la vie.
Et effectivement, Voltaire s’achète et rénove de
belles propriétés (comme les châteaux de Ferney et
de Tournay, pas loin de Genève) ; il organise
de luxueuses soirées ; et il voyage (ce qui
était bien plus coûteux à l’époque).
Mais sa vie ne se résume pas à ça !
Malgré sa fortune, Voltaire
est un gros travailleur.
Les plaisirs ne l’empêchent pas de rester de
longues heures à son bureau, à lire et à écrire.
Il produit par sa seule puissance de travail une
œuvre considérable : des poèmes, des pièces de
théâtre, des articles, des pamphlets, des essais
philosophiques, un dictionnaire philosophique,
des contes, ou encore des essais historiques.
Pourquoi travaille-t-il autant ?
Il est tout d’abord en quête de
reconnaissance artistique.
À la vingtaine, il veut être reconnu
comme le meilleur poète français.
C’est son théâtre (en vers) qui le fait
accéder à la gloire : il est le plus grand
auteur dramatique du XVIIIe siècle.
Ensuite, Voltaire jouit de son pouvoir
d’influence. Certains historiens de la philosophie
estiment même qu’aucun écrivain n’a eu autant
d’influence de son vivant.
« Mon métier, affirme-t-il,
c’est de dire ce que je pense. »